now you might want to think twice about
getting a hysterectomy of course
check with your doctor before taking on
that recommendation which that sounds
kind of weird but i had to give that
disclaimer but i want to talk about the
serious consequences and side effects
from hysterectomies
first thing you need to know is that 90
of all hysterectomies
are not life-threatening okay because
one of the reasons they do them is
cancer
but that's less than eight percent
okay
the great majority of hysterectomies are
basically
unnecessary and you should really know
what you're getting yourself into
it's the second most common female
surgery behind c-sections
and if someone tells you well you're
approaching menopause and
you really don't need your ovaries
because they stop working don't buy that
the ovaries continue to work beyond
menopause okay they produce significant
amounts of androgens which then can be
turned into
estrogen
and if your doctor disagrees with you
just ask them
then why do i need hormone replacement
therapy after i have a full hysterectomy
well it's actually because you don't
have the ovaries to produce
those female hormones anymore
okay consequences the side effects of
hysterectomy well the big one is going
to change your figure in a very negative
way
because when you cut
this band of ligaments that are attached
to the uterus those ligaments are also
attached to the spine
the hips
part of your pelvis
and basically you're collapsing the
internal part of your torso the core of
the inside of your mid section that
causes the hips to widen that causes the
rib cage to shift
downward it can also give you a
shortened thick midsection appearance
and a protruded belly and many times
when you hopefully see an informed
consent
you don't really see this side effect
number two lower back pain why because
you just created a lot of instability in
your pelvis not to mention
the potential for a leaky bladder
and a loss of libido which is number
four number five emotional rollercoaster
it can really affect your emotions
because if there's any fluctuations
of estrogen
or progesterone downward or upward and
that can affect your emotional state of
mind
number six fatigue number seven it can
increase your risk of getting fractures
because
now you're in a state where you could
potentially get either osteopenia or
osteoporosis because of the loss of
estrogen number eight it can increase
your risk of all-cause mortality
including coronary heart disease
now sometimes they'll say well you know
you're going to take your ovaries out
that way it can decrease your risk of
potentially getting ovarian cancer down
the road so you're going to take out an
organ
to prevent cancer from developing in
that organ which by the way ovarian
cancer
is rare especially if you're going to
compare the death from overhang cancer
to the increased risk of dying from a
hysterectomy
this is a much greater risk than getting
ovarian cancer and dying from ovarian
cancer number nine an average female who
has a hysterectomy gains 25 pounds
within the first year now instead of
getting hysterectomy why don't we then
identify the reason for the hysterectomy
okay
let's take a look at that
all right we have
fibroids okay we have endometriosis
already talked about cancer
excessive bleeding or heavy cycles okay
what could you do
to resolve these
that would be a new concept well number
one black cohosh is pretty effective for
uterine fibroids
number two i would highly recommend you
avoid soy especially the soy protein
isolates in so many different foods and
it can affect estrogen sensitive tissue
like the uterus
like the ovary
the cervix and other tissues even the
thyroid you don't want to be either
taking extra estrogen or consuming
foods that are estrogenic this is why i
also recommend if you have fibroids or
endometriosis to avoid dairy because
dairy is
originally designed to help grow a calf
so there's a lot of growth hormones in
there so anything that increases growth
you want to avoid and there's several
hormones that will do that estrogen will
do it
and insulin will do it as well so that's
why going on a low-carb diet would be
smart insulin is anabolic it makes
things get bigger but so is estrogen so
you want to avoid soy dairy and carbs
especially the refined carbohydrates of
course you can have vegetables as in the
cruciferous vegetables cruciferous
vegetables are
they help balance the estrogen they're
not going to increase more estrogen
they're going to shift from the bad
estrogen to the good estrogen but they
also detoxify the liver of things that
can mimic estrogen as in endocrine
disruptors so there are certain things
in the environment
pesticides insecticides herbicides
fungicides heavy metals plastics
this is an herbicide glyphosate it's in
all the different gmo foods right
these chemicals in the environment are
endocrine disruptors but they also mimic
estrogen okay
so what we want to do is we want to go
organic we want to really limit the
exposure to chemicals
and at the same time consume cruciferous
vegetables that can help detoxify these
chemicals from your body
also there's a interesting correlation
between vitamin d deficiency
in fibroids and endometriosis so i would
just recommend getting enough vitamin d
if you have fibroids endometriosis or
even heavy periods because think about
it the uterus is a muscle right
so it needs calcium it needs magnesium
when you
take vitamin d what do you do you
increase the absorption
of calcium and other minerals and what's
better for a cramp than having more of
these minerals the other thing i wanted
to mention related to glyphosate it
blocks vitamin a and there's some
research i'll put it down below
that
shows the connection between low vitamin
a
and developing
fibroids okay and i'm not saying you
should start taking vitamin a of course
you should eat the foods high in vitamin
a like butter
cod oil
egg yolks that would be beneficial
but i'm just pointing it out in case
that might be your situation now one
last point let's say you already had a
hysterectomy okay
is there anything else you can do
in addition to what i talked about right
here
yes there is a really wonderful product
from standard process i'm not affiliated
with them anymore but standard process
has a product called utrophin
pmg
okay eutrophin pmg
i would take that i would recommend
taking maybe two two of those before you
go to bed
the second thing i would take if you had
your ovaries removed is another product
from standard process called ovutrophin
pmg
okay so overtrophing pmg take one of
those before bed and it's likely that
you'll see an improvement in your
symptoms
and that goes beyond what i recommended
right here
now since we're on the topic of female
hormones there's a really good video on
estrogen that i would highly recommend
and i put it up right here check it out